I'm meeting Mohammed Elua in erfurt here
he is finally safe but he's worried
about his future for one thing the 26
year old is waiting for the answer to
his request for asylum he is worried
about things that others take for
granted finding an apartment for example
and a job in his profession as lab
technician a kid he can't i'm happy that
i arrived in germany safe and sounds I'm
happy but I also know that many
obstacles lie ahead i first have to get
past them then I'll be able to relax
Mohamed Elua shows me how he traveled to
germany via turkey at the start he was
detained by the Turkish Coast Guard then
he reached the Greek island of lesbos
then it only took him five days to reach
the German border but his flight began
much earlier than that journey three
years ago Mohammed's left his home in
Syria in Jordan here to wait for several
months to begin his journey to Europe we
met him for the first time when he left
the country we joined him when he had to
say goodbye to his family preparations
for the journey to Germany Mohammed Elua
lived in the city of irbid in Jordan for
3 years together with his mother and
siblings his father was sick and had to
stay in Syria it's hard to say goodbye
but he doesn't see a future in Jordan
but the Emily no Dallas well I have
completely given up hope of ever
returning to Syria there's a lot of
pressure on us young people which is
hard to bear and it not only affects my
work it affects my private life as well
mal bahadir esta mala yeah yeah fish
Emmett I have absolutely no hope for a
political solution at home there's only
bombs death and destruction there our
house was destroyed and I have not seen
my husband for more than three years the
next morning an effort we look at the
footage from Jordan together at that
time he was full of hope but now he is
plagued by a guilty conscience just a
few weeks ago his father was killed
during air strikes in Syria Mohammed
feels that he has abandoned his family
callosotomy when that report was made my
father was still alive that's what I
find most moving right now there is
definitely no going back anymore its
final when someone you love dies then
there is no place to return to match fee
amanillah nadja mohammed wants to
establish a new home in germany he is
taking german lessons every day at a
language school in erfurt I named Hank
DMI affect his dream is to stand on his
own feet again as quickly as possible
and to bring his family over uncle but
he knows that it will be a long journey
before he will be able to achieve those
goals